[Applause]
the taliban advance is happening more
quickly and more successfully than
probably anybody feared it would
[Music]
they are dragging the dead through the
streets as a warning to anyone who gets
in their way
they've captured weapons and equipment
as well this is an afghan army humvee
being driven by a taliban fighter
the situation is under control in the
city our fighters are patrolling in the
city all the people are very happy the
mujahideen of islamic emirate are
assuring people that there is nothing to
worry about this was the map of
afghanistan's provinces back in april
taliban controlled territory is in red
look how fast it changes as nato forces
withdrew the taliban now controls
two-thirds of afghan territory although
the major cities are still in government
hands
and these are the provincial capitals
that have fallen in just the last six
days
afghan forces have reportedly been
surrendering to the taliban unable to
hold their ground now that nato support
has been withdrawn
lash kaga the capital of hellmann
province is now encircled
british forces spent years protecting
and rebuilding this part of the country
and now it is about to fall back into
taliban hands the open clashes are all
the way around the city nobody is able
to move safely and it's affecting uh
affecting everything this is affecting
life itself there are a lot of
internally displaced people in this
moment
everybody who had somewhere to go fled
the city
u.s intelligence now predicts that the
capital kabul could fall within months
that would be game over
but even faced with that president biden
is sticking firm to his decision and the
pentagon says the afghans must fight
their own battles these are younger more
rigid more extremist hard-blooded
taliban leaders and commanders who have
been massively influenced by al-qaeda
and other foreign fighters over the last
20 years
they are also equipped with some of the
most lethal weapons
the afghan president ashraf ghani is now
trying to rally the regional warlords
that he had previously ignored but there
will be a price for their support
with nato troops gone the future of
afghanistan is being decided by force
not diplomacy as the west believed and
hoped it would be
alistair sky news